Narrator: Tails are like opinions.
Basically, everyone has them: fish, birds,
most reptiles, and even some
of our closest relatives.
So why are we missing out?
Since tails first evolved at
least 500 million years ago,
they've taken on every role imaginable.
Geckos use them to store fat.
Birds use them to steer through the air,
and rattlesnakes use them
to scare off predators.
But for most mammals, they
serve one major purpose:
balance.
Yet, as you get closer to
humans on the evolutionary tree,
tails disappear. Gorillas don't have them,
and neither do chimps or any other apes,
including us, of course.
To understand why, take
a look at how we walk.
Some of us primates crouch
with our chest held diagonally
to the ground. Others
like gibbons and humans
can walk completely upright.
Now, walking like this
gives us a huge advantage
because unlike four-legged animals,
which have to pour energy
into every step they take,
two legs take advantage of gravity,
which does some of the work for us.
You see, each time we take a step,
gravity pulls us forward.
The end result is that when we walk,
we use around 25% less energy
than walking on all fours.
And in the wild, every
ounce of energy you save
can mean the difference between
survival and starvation.
But this way of getting
around also totally
eliminates the need for a tail
because even though a human head
weighs a hefty 5 kilograms,
it sits on top of the body when you walk,
not in front, so you don't need
a tail as a counterbalance.
Pretty disappointing, huh?
That being said, you
can still see a reminder
of a time when our ancient
primate ancestors had one.
Just look at a human spine.
You can see how the last few bones
are partially fused together.
That's your tailbone.
It's all that's left of our tail,
and, yes, it's sad and
pathetic, and you can't wag it.
Now, in rare cases, babies are born
with what looks like a tail,
but that's not what's really going on.
Most often, these tails
are actually tumors,
cysts, or even a parasitic twin.
Even more occasionally, they're a true
outgrowth of the spine but
are completely boneless,
a soft tube made entirely
of fat and tissue.
These types of tails usually
form as a birth defect,
a deformity of the spine
called spina bifida.
And in these situations,
doctors will surgically
remove the tails with no harm to the baby.
But as cool as it might
sound to have an extra limb
to swing through the trees
or keep mosquitoes away,
we are who we are today
because, well, we don't.